what was the biggest thing you learned
about politics during the camp during
your campaign I was educated on the role
of the media I'm not sure I've spoken
about this openly but like I spoke at an
event Iowa's one of the first events I
did and the headline speaker at this
event was Michael avenatti
and this was when he was talking about
running for president and so I gave and
it was like my big political speech
debut now I had like practiced at
everything it was like and then Michael
avenatti spoke and as far as the
journalists in the room were concerned
it's like if your gang didn't exist and
it was like oh and I thought objectively
Michael gave a bad speech I thought I
was like well that was shitty he just
like read every word he went five
minutes over I thought the applause was
like polite and then the journalists in
attendance were like Michael avatar do
you think and I was like what is going
on like that like that's that doesn't
seem to me to be like an objective
depiction of reality like the story was
our almost pre-written
[Music]
you
[Music]